you're just making excuses don't be gun
excuses you can find opportunities don't
accept excuses but we've got no time for
excuses and I'll have an excuse no
excuses no chooses my friends no longer
wallow in my self-pity maybe it's my own
fault
maybe I led you to believe it was easy
when it wasn't
maybe I made you think my highlight
started at the free-throw line and not
in the gym maybe I made you think that
every shot I took was a game-winner
if my game was built on flash and not
fired
maybe it's my fault that you didn't see
that failure gave me strength that my
pain was my motivation
they better led you to believe that
basketball was a guy given gift and not
something I work every single day of my
life
maybe I destroyed the game
oh maybe you just making excuses the
thing about being an entrepreneur is
this it's just all to you you know a lot
of people like to make excuses I don't
have connections I don't have money I
don't have this but you know if you find
something that you like to do or love to
do be great at it and see if you can
turn it into a business and worst case
you're going to have fun doing what it
is you love to do in best case you can
turn it into a business I I'm just not
big on excuses I just think if you
really everybody had that opportunity to
go for it they just got to do it we have
a lot of we have a Alibaba Group we have
a team or group we have a tarball group
with a lipe and people say how you make
it why this make it why people cannot
have fun opportunities you can find
opportunities and I think people same
here today Jeff where is the opportunity
I don't have a job I don't have this I
don't have a debt I remember 20 years
ago
I hate a Bill Gates I say he took all
the job you know he's such a great Larry
Page Bill Gates and every success people
they did good and why I don't have this
chance the same question like you later
I come down myself and luckily I win I
tell you unlucky to know a lot of famous
people Bill Gates Warren Buffet the Jack
Welch Larry Page Mark Zuckerberg I know
all of that I would like to share with
you that those people the difference
between those people and other people
they are always optimistic for the
future they never complain they always
try to solve the problems of the others
and I think where is the opportunity the
opportunity lie always lies in the place
where people complain some people sit
there complain you think if I can solve
that complaint that's the opportunity I
was I had a horrible temper poor
self-esteem all the things that you
think would preclude success but I had
something very important I had a mother
who believed in me and I had a mother
who would never allow herself to be a
victim no matter what happened never
made excuses and she never accepted an
excuse from us and if we ever came up
with an excuse she said do you have a
brain and if the answer was yes then she
said then you could have thought your
way out of it it doesn't matter with
John or Susan or Mary or anybody else
did or said and it was the most
important thing she did for my brother
and myself because if you don't accept
excuses pretty soon people stop giving
them and they start looking for
solutions and that is a critical issue
when it comes to success we know that
too many young men in our community
continue to make bad choices and I have
to say growing up I made quite a few
myself sometimes I wrote off my own
failings as just as another example of
the world trying to keep a black man
down I had a tendency sometimes to make
excuses for me not doing the right thing
but one of the things that all of you
have learned over the last four years is
there's no longer any room for excuses
I understand there's a common fraternity
Creed here at Morehouse excuses are
tools of the incompetent used to build
bridges to nowhere and monuments of
nothingness but we've got no time for
excuses not because the bitter legacy of
slavery and segregation have banished
entirely they have not not because
racism and discrimination no longer
exists we know those are still out there
it's just that in today's
hyper-connected hyper competitive world
with millions of young people from China
and India and Brazil many of whom
started with a whole lot less than all
of you did all of them entering the
global workforce alongside you nobody is
going to give you anything that you have
not earned nobody cares how tough your
upbringing was nobody cares if you
suffered some discrimination
and moreover you have to remember that
whatever you've gone through it pales in
comparison to the hardships previous
generations endured and they overcame
them and if they overcame them you can
overcome up to my son's 14 is fabulous
and we're having this conversation about
when he plays in sports or when he does
something about you go full out or do
you not and I see sometimes in him that
when he's out on the field of doing
something he doesn't play full out and
I'll have an excuse like my leg hurts or
my arm hurts or something happened the
coach was unfair what other hanger the
referee was unfair and what happens with
people is we tend to go out into the
world and we look for those sort of
excuses about why things aren't the way
we want them and when you do that you
lose all your power in life when you
start focusing on the external on your
excuses you lose your power here is the
way people really think I will tell you
I can go out onto stage and bomb you go
out there you just bomb right and people
will respect you for going out there and
trying your hardest it's not how you
actually perform that earns you the
respect of your peers it's the fact that
you went out and actually did it that's
the difference I decided to go to film
school because I loved the idea of
making films I loved photography and
everybody said it was a crazy thing to
do because in those days nobody made it
into the film business I mean just
unless you were related to somebody
there was no way in so everything is
silly you're never going to get a job
but I I wasn't moved by that I set the
goal of getting through film school and
just that's focused on getting to that
level because I did you know I didn't
know where I was going to go after that
I wanted to make documentary films and
eventually I got into the goal of once I
got to school of making a film one of
the most telling things about film
schools you got a lot of students in
those days especially it's not quite so
much today but wandering around say oh I
wish I could make a movie I wish I
make a movie you know I can't get in
this class I can't get any you know
first class I have was an animation
class it wasn't a production class I had
a history class on and an animation
class and in the animation class they
gave us one minute of film to put onto
the animation camera to operate it to
see how you could move left move right
make it go up and down and it was a test
to see you know then the teacher would
you had certain requirements you had to
do you had to make it go up man and make
her go down and then the teacher would
look at it and say oh yes you maneuvered
this machine to do these things and I
took that one minute of film and made it
into a movie and it was a movie that won
like you know 20 or 25 Awards you know
in every film festival in the world and
kind of changed the whole animation
Department and in meanwhile all the
other guys were and so well I wish I
could make lluvia which is a production
class and so then I got into another
class and it wasn't really a production
class but I managed to get some film
when I made a movie and I made lots of
movies while I'm in school while
everybody else are running around saying
oh I wish I could make a movie at early
so speaking of excuses one of my other
favorite ones is no excuses no victim
mentality the world owes you nothing the
world might come help you but I wouldn't
count on it and if you start from the
feeling that you need the world to
participate in order for you to be
successful at taking on this new thing
that you're considering doing you're
right to be scared a mite I wouldn't
count on it though but if you start from
the perspective that the world owes you
nothing which it doesn't and then it is
not likely to bring you any particular
help you have nothing to lose because
really isn't that for every one of the
people you brought onto team isn't that
how you want them to feel when they
report to you you know what excuses that
doesn't mean that you can't fail or that
they can't ever fail but right when
you're starting you have nothing to lose
right when you're
a huge company you can spend 99% of your
time worrying how not to mess up the
billion-dollar year money hoes you've
created but you don't have a billion
dollar your money hoes right now you
have nothing so you can't lose spend 99%
of your time imagining what would happen
if things went well and planning for
that because there's no downside it's
like a free option on an adventure
Roberto asks what do you feel is a
bigger obstacle to success a lack of
time or lack of capital Roberto this is
a tremendous question I think the
biggest obstacle to success is a lack of
optimism that question in itself is the
problem my friend right you're looking
at two things that are both negatives
and guess what
both of them are obstacles when I
started winelibrary.com transformation
for my business I had time I worked my
face off every minute but we don't have
a whole lot of money in our profit
Center
so it took more time right it's just the
way it is today I have more money but
boy don't I have time but neither ever
ever will be an excuse for me and so
just a drill dhis
through the throat of the vaynernation
that's right I went that graphic don't
smile d-roc here's the bottom line I
refuse to allow you to get an answer to
that question because both of them are
firmly square in the excuse column and I
have no patience for that there will
always be problems let's talk about a
million other things that are a way to
stop success the health and well-being
of your family members so it takes your
mind away from execution the country you
live in government and political you
know concepts at these moments I lost
startups in China that I've invested in
that got traction but then people that
were wired into the government decided
to not allow it to happen and then the
startup disappeared not as easy to be an
entrepreneur there it's still a
communist country sorry it just is and
so all these things can be problems
right there's a competitor with a
billion dollars who's also skilled and
punches you in the mouth and knocks you
out in the first round right the world
changing I mean there's just a million
obstacles right the media one bad
coverage of you a moment in time you
know what I think about a lot you know
what I think about a lot let's get
really real this is why we did this show
I always I'm a human being and I always
think about a moment in time what if I
just say the wrong thing at the wrong
time right what if I call out China for
being a communist country in an episode
while I'm on a rant and somebody who's
watching doesn't like the way that
tastes and it takes away a business
opportunity for me in China in seven
years even though I'm not trying to zing
it's just things that I saw what if what
if you know what if what if I look down
on my phone while I'm driving even
though I've really not done that and I
hit somebody and I kill them and that
becomes the story and I like forget
about the story about what you think of
me I will never recover from that
because I killed somebody because I
needed to check a tweet these are
moments in time so there are so many
things that can keep you from being
successful right the people that you
invested in having something bad
happened to them so it slows you down my
friends there are a million reasons why
not
but there's one great reason why which
is you've just got a persevere no matter
what it is it's just the way it is it's
hard being an entrepreneur it's hard
building a business everybody thinks
it's so easy that there's an entitlement
there's a disaster zinging China here
comes my us thing right now there is an
insane generation of 18 to 25 year olds
right now that think they're entitled to
having a business because they saw the
social network movie and everybody's
decided if you're a kid and you know
what Tech is because you used Instagram
early on you're entitled to actually
build a business building a business is
hard and you know what makes it really
hard everything that happens every day
of every moment so you can pick time you
can pick money as the one or two things
that you think stopped you from winning
your game but the truth is there's a
million reasons 99 percent of businesses
go out of business for a reason and that
reason is it's hard and so if you're
watching this show I've got a sense of
who you are and you need to start
creating layers and layers and layers
and layers of skin to be able to get
through because
the glamour of being an entrepreneur the
goodness you know you get very confused
by my optimism because it's my optimism
I can't help it it's just how I roll
it's probably one of the variable 1%
reasons why I'm successful but please
don't get it twisted this is hard every
day is hard and if you don't have the
stomach to weather the storm you will
not be successful and by the way let me
throw you a real weird curveball and
that's okay people have to look
themselves in a mirror and understand if
they're number 2 3 4 5 6 7 in an
organization that has differences of
being a number one but maybe that's
where your skill set sits maybe that's
how you make your fortunes and happiness
and all the things that you're looking
for and so that question got me going a
little bit Steve because it's endured a
context of excuses and I will never make
an excuse everything that's a problem
with me everything I don't achieve
everything that's a problem at
vaynermedia and everything is my fault
and I I succumb to that and I respect
that and I actually think that's the way
it should be
and so um no excuses my friends when I
had open-heart saving I died I used to I
used to ask myself I just wanted to
myself I used to ask the good Lord I was
a pregnant
why why did this happen have to happen
to me I felt like I was a pretty good
person I tried to treat everybody right
I wasn't prejudiced god I loved
everybody I didn't care what Kody was I
loved so why why did the lower kidney
mean why'd it have to be the the
fortunate one or unfortunate however you
want to look at to be stricken down and
have to suffer like this for a year and
a half after my surgery 18 months 18
months 6 months I had to spend in a
wheelchair 6 more months I had to sleep
sitting down on the floor with my back
up against the wall because if I lay
down I couldn't breathe they had to cut
my diaphragm during the surgery a whole
lot of complication anywhere I've sit
there I asked a good Lord
why did I have to go through this why
why was I mind you do this to me and it
got so bad so bad the pain was so bad my
hurt was so bad times done
I used to say Lord if I'm gonna have to
live like this for the rest of my life
then just take me take me now I don't
want to suffer like this anymore I went
to one of many many many doctor visits
that I had at the VA hospital a young
doctor approached me came up to me sick
CT I heard it used to be the champion of
the world I raised my head up but I had
a little little little inkling of pride
still left and I say yes I'm won and you
heard about I'm the one that they told
stories about yes I'm Ct Fletcher he
said what in tho happened to you
man-boy you know that hurt me that hurt
me down deep but I tell you what if that
doctor was here today I would thank him
because his snide comment is what made
me determine to no longer wallow in my
self-pity
- no longer ask God why did he do this
to me my determination changed from that
day on I want to prove to that little
smart wise but I could come back that I
will still see T foots now I'm gonna let
his little smart
be right I'm not down I'm not done I'm
not through it's over when I say so and
not before thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know which of the
clips you liked the most and are you
going to stop making excuses or do you
make too many excuses I'd love to hear
your story share it in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon